es un informe que el propio partido de
extrema derecha de mahin lupen la
agrupación nacional había investigado en
un intento por frenar las acusaciones de
sus vínculos con Rusia en lugar de eso
el informe detallazo acogedora relación
y lo pen no pudo ocultar su enfado
después de que se filtraran extratos a
los medios franceses
este informe es un reflejo del ponente
el sectario deshonesto y totalmente
politizado la realidad de este informe
es que no hay nada
para el informe que aún no se ha
publicado formalmente una comisión
multipartidista examinó las injerencias
extranjeras en la vida política y
económica francesa subrayan los
contactos frecuentes entre diputados de
la agrupación nacional y funcionarios
rusos y el encubrimiento público por
parte del partido del accionar ruso en
particular en lo que respecta a la
anexión de crimea por parte de Moscú en
2014 que Lupe defendió en repetidas
ocasiones la comisión entrevistó una
serie de figuras clave incluida luip en
la semana pasada donde negó cualquier
contrapartida política a cambio del
préstamo ruso contratado por su partido
en 2014 firmé un préstamo con un banco
no firmé un préstamo con Vladimir Putin
no me compromete a nada
el informe también afirma que Rusia le
devolvió el favor refiriéndose a una
reunión entre el open y Vladimir Putin
en marzo de 2017 menos de cuatro semanas
antes de las elecciones presidenciales
francesas una reunión que solo la prensa
rusa pudo cubrir y que era muy esperado
por lupein que quería reforzar su
prestigio internacional según el informe
que se publicará íntegramente el lunes